I don't love the ending of the mood
because you can read those that final
shot one of three ways you can either
say that that that Chris survived and
he's standing there and you know and the
kid has learned you know what Chris
taught him about the swimming pool and
holding your breath the other way of
course is that he's learned everything
there is to know about Chris's character
and he's training to be like Chris
the other possibility of course is that
that's someone who just looks like Chris
slightly out of frame who's now watching
so do you have an opinion I mean our our
approach and I know Sam's approach is
that is a poetic shot right it's meant
to have an open interpretation it could
represent it is meant to represent hope
and it could represent the boys hope in
in a future that he had a guardian
watching over him and now he's got a
shot at a normal life but you could
interpret it any way you want to
interpret it that he's alive or that
this is a figment of his imagination Sam
told me that we're talking about test
screenings in the editing process and he
said when they tested the film that 50%
of the audience wanted Chris to live and
like 50 percent of the audience was okay
with him dying and which for me if
you're trying to figure out which
direction to go that's pretty crazy when
half the audience
you know you see what I'm saying for
sure and I think that that's the beauty
of you know having a poetic shot at the
end of the film is that you can walk
away from the movie with your own
interpretation of it you know you know
it is a oppressive movie in what in a
lot of ways it's emotionally wrought and
it was important for us that there there
was hope for the boy at the end of the
film